hi folks it's me dr. Johnson the urge
there was no honest way to explain it
because the only people who really know
where it is are the ones who have gone
over these are the perfect words to
describe the life of Hunter s Thompson
he was a writer who is best known for
his semi autobiographical novel Fear and
Loathing in Las Vegas he was also the
founder of gonzo journalism he has gone
down in history as being one of the
wildest writers in American history
[Music]
Hunter s Thomson was born in Louisville
Kentucky on July the 18th 1937 his
father Jack was World War one veteran
and an insurance salesman he was
suffering from a disease called
myasthenia gravis and passed away when
Hunter was just 14 years old his mother
Virginia was a librarian and she was
left to shoulder all of the
responsibilities alone she struggled
financially and began drinking heavily
to cope with her grief Hunter was very
intelligence and it's really no surprise
that being raised by a librarian helped
him in his love of books when he entered
high school he joined a club called the
Athenaeum literary Association they
wrote a newsletter together and Thompson
was always very witty and sarcastic
through this literary society became
friends with the rich kids in town since
they were the only ones who shared his
passion for reading and writing most of
the boys in Kentucky enjoyed practicing
marksmanship and hunting wild animals in
the woods Hunter he did as well but he
was sort of caught in between both of
the worlds since his family was so poor
he felt like an outsider to his new
friend group his friends began to
vandalize and participated in robberies
in his local neighborhoods and they were
even able to get alcohol despite being
underage one night they were caught by
the police and kept in custody his
friends all had rich parents who were
able to pay lawyers and get them bail
unfortunately fanta his mother could not
afford to pay for his legal-defense
ended up serving time in jail and could
not attend his own high school
graduation in 1956 he decided to join
the US Air Force but he wasn't exactly
good at taking orders he began writing
for the Air Force Base newspaper but his
defamatory claims got him in so much
trouble that he was discharged in 1957
[Music]
all writers have an author that they
look up to and Hunter s Thompson's
favorite authors were f scott Fitzgerald
and Hemingway he would read The Great
Gatsby
and a farewell to arms and wished that
he could write with that same kind of
emotion he decided that he would copy
the book word-for-word on his typewriter
over and over again just to feel the
rhythm of what it was like to write his
favorite books he spent a year living in
Rio de Janeiro writing for the
english-language newspaper called the
Brazil Herald this gig only lasted a
year though and he returned to the
United States to marry his longtime
girlfriend Sondhi Wright in 1963 they
moved to Aspen Colorado together instead
of working on a staff he became a
freelance journalist making roughly $100
per article he would hunt elk so he and
his wife had something to eat but they
barely ate any food aside from that
there were many months when they almost
didn't make their rent they had a son
together named Kwan Fitzgerald Thompson
sadly zombie suffered through five more
miscarriages and one remains their only
child in 1964 Hunter S Thompson reported
on the suicide of Hemingway in Idaho he
stole some antlers and a skull that have
been hanging on the wall from the famous
writer as a souvenir hunter and his
family they then moved to California and
he encountered hippie culture in San
Francisco for the first time he was
given an assignment by a publication
called the nation requesting that he do
an investigative piece on the motorcycle
gang called the Hells Angels they were
known for being incredibly dangerous and
purposely trying to break all of the
rules of society many journalists and
attempted to write about the gang before
but they were too afraid to get involved
but humza he was wild enough to hang and
he fit in just fine during one of the
parties Thompson witnessed one of the
gang members beating his wife and his
dog Hunter then approached the man
saying only a punk beats his wife and
Doc the gang beat up Thompson for
defending the man's wife his face was a
pulp and his ribs are broken he went to
the police station and reported the
beatings to the authorities it was that
point that he realized he didn't really
want to be involved with the Hells
Angels any longer Thompson wrote I was
finished the Angels had taken me to the
edge there could be no going back now
even if I wanted to honza compiled his
articles into a book called Hells Angels
a strange and terrible saga he was given
a fifteen thousand dollar cheque as an
advance and he used the money to buy a
house and some land in Aspen Colorado
which he named owl farm and he lived
there for the rest of his life when the
book was part
it was on the New York Times bestseller
list despite the success hunter wanted
to continue to push himself to do better
with his writing career after the time
he spent with house angels hunter as
Thompson formed an obsession with
collecting guns he used them to hunts
but he was also interested in
marksmanship and practiced shooting
targets on a daily basis is also
probably not a coincidence that he
started collecting guns after becoming
hated by one of the most violent gangs
in the country
even after the success of his first book
comes arrest Thompson was still a
freelance journalist his success helped
him secure work various magazines where
he offered to cover sporting events
while working for Scanlon's monthly he
became friends with an illustrator named
Ralph Steadman and he introduced him
drugs for the first time Steadman took a
psilocybin mushrooms before they went to
go watch the 1970 Kentucky Derby during
the race Steadman Illustrated the people
in the crowds who were watching gambling
and drinking their drugs greatly
heightens the atmosphere of the race for
them the article he ultimately wrote
about the event was titled the Kentucky
Derby is decadent and depraved after
that piece was published one of
Thompson's co-workers commented that
piece was totally gonzo as in it was
totally nuts at first Thompson felt as
if the piece had been one of his biggest
failures and he decided that he would
never do drugs before writing again to
his surprise though he began to get
phone calls from people who called him
brilliant he realized that the style of
writing was actually working in his
favor and he decided to call it gonzo
journalism he later said I hate to
advocate drugs alcohol violence or
insanity to anyone but they've always
worked for me he continued this gonzo
style in Fear and Loathing in Las Vegas
what should have been a relatively
boring day in the desert reporting on a
motorcycle race became a psychedelic
adventure about searching for the
American dream
Rolling Stone he really wanted a few
paragraphs describing the race but
hunter had come back with a 60 page
manifesto about everything had
experienced while high on drugs the
story was published and he got a book
deal with Random House Publishing after
the success of Fear and Loathing in Las
Vegas
Hunter s Thompson sought this as
evidence that he needed to continue his
wild lifestyle he began to take drugs
and drink pretty much every day of his
life
Hunter s Thompson once wrote out his
daily routine where he consumed so many
substances it is truly a miracle that he
didn't die of a heart attack 3 p.m. rise
3:05 Shiva Sri go with the morning
papers Dunhill's 3:45 cocaine 405 first
cup of coffee Dunhill then between 4:00
and 5:00 p.m. he snorts more cocaine at
6 p.m. he smokes grass to take the edge
off the day then finally he leaves at
7:05 p.m. to the Woody Creek tavern for
lunch
Heineken two margaritas cole slaw a taco
salad a double order of fried onion
rings carrot cake ice cream a bean
fritter Dunhill's another Heineken
cocaine
and for the ride home a snowcone a glass
of shredded ice over which is poured
three or four jiggers of shivers 9 a.m.
starts snorting cocaine seriously this
goes on into a midnight when he finally
starts writing until 8 a.m. when he
falls asleep many people know about
Hunter s Thompson's reputation for
getting high and shooting guns but far
fewer people know about his attempt at
establishing a political career in 1968
he witnessed the rats at the Democratic
National Convention and wrote that the
brutality shown by the police beating
protesters was 10 times worse than
anything it ever witnessed while living
with the Hells Angels he wrote that the
American Dream was clubbing itself to
death Thompson believed that the city of
Aspen was being destroyed because trees
were being torn down to make way for new
roads and luxury homes for people who
were coming to have a skiing holiday he
wanted a push for preserving the natural
landscape and making marijuana legal in
Colorado this attention to its campaign
brought a lot of hippies to visit Aspen
in 1970 he wrote about the mayoral
election of 1969 for Rolling Stone
magazine and he titled the article the
Battle of Aspen he got such a huge
response from readers that he decided
that he would run for sheriff of Pitkin
County Colorado in 1970 at first his
campaign sort of started as a joke
because he knew that he had absolutely
no experience in politics but the longer
it went on the more we started to
believe that he could actually win he
convinced a lot of people to register to
vote who had never participated in a
local election before his campaign team
began to hang posters around town with
his logo of a raised fist with two
thumbs holding a peyote cactus this
became known as the gonzo fist Hunter
was balding so he asked the barber to
completely shave his head just so he
could deliver a joke in his speech
unlike my long haired opponents he got
into the habit of wearing long
ridiculous wigs one of the editors of
Rolling Stone said during an interview
that undressed Thompson was switching
out his wigs multiple times during one
conversation his friends helped tons at
film a commercial for his campaign which
was basically just him riding a
motorcycle but his fans they loved it
all the same
the only thing against him is he's a
visionary he wants to cure the world not
surprisingly he lost the election and he
never got to serve as sheriff but it did
inspiring to continue writing about
politics in fear and loathing on the
campaign trail 72 he began to get a bit
of a reputation for being an anarchist
rather than a real journalist since he
was not trying to become a political
reporter full-time Hunter s Thompson he
was not afraid to insult the politicians
and anyone else that he noticed was
acting ridiculously on the campaign
trail he also didn't need to worry about
burning political bridges because he
wasn't gonna be there long anyway
because of his brutal honesty his
journalism caught the attention of the
politicians more than the typical
articles that were being written about
them he absolutely hated Richard Nixon
with a fiery passion he compared him and
his family to Barbie dolls
he said that Nixon represented
everything that was wrong with the
United States even when he died Thompson
wrote a scathing eulogy in Rolling Stone
where the subject line said the death of
Richard Nixon notes on the passing of an
American monster he was a liar and a
quitter and he should have been buried
at sea but he was after all the
president in his books on politics he
sought to see if it was even possible
for a good man to become a politician he
concluded that George McGovern was the
closest thing to a good man on the
campaign trail but of course he didn't
win the presidential election just like
all of the subjects that he wrote about
he felt that this was just another one
where the American dream was dead during
the next election Hunter s Thompson
wrote about Jimmy Carter on the campaign
trail and many people believed that his
articles actually helped him become
presidents at that point people trusted
his insights into the character of these
politicians Thompson became one of the
most memorable political writers of his
time and he broke every single rule
along the way
in 1980 Bill Murray starred in a comedy
movie called where the buffalo roam
which was based on his various exploits
as journalists because they used his
real name in the movie this launched
Thompson to a new level of Fame he also
inspired a character called Uncle Duke
in the doonesbury comic strip Thompson
became friends with other celebrities
like Jimmy Buffett Bob Dylan Jack
Nicholson and Bill Murray he struggled
with the fact that everyone imagined him
as this caricature of the person that
they saw in Fear and Loathing in Las
Vegas and the comic strip it made him
feel like people have this expectation
that he should behave gonzo 24/7 because
of that he began to show up to
interviews completely high or acting
crazy because he thought that that's
what people expected of him during an
interview with the BBC he said that the
myth of his caricature had become bigger
than who he truly was he stated most
people are surprised that I walk on two
legs the idea that I would have a wife
or a child I think people think I'm a
violent version of that comic strip he
also stated about the myth this myth is
growing and mushrooming and getting more
and more warped when I get invited to
speak to universities I don't know who
they're inviting Duke or Thompson I'm
not sure who to be it makes me want to
kill off one life and start another one
he reached a point where even if people
had not read his articles or books they
knew him from the movies in the comic
groupies began to flirt with him and
flock to the Woody Creek tavern because
it was well known that he loved to hang
out there or even after he became famous
when he was awake he was invited
strangers over to the house and of
parties
Hunter was caught having multiple
affairs with these women eventually his
wife had a knife and she asked for a
divorce in 1980 at this point he was
such a successful and famous writer that
the editor at rolling stone did not know
what kind of assignments to give him
anymore it almost seemed as though
nothing was worthy of Hunter s Thompson
he was assigned to cover a boxing match
with Muhammad Ali because he had written
about him successfully in the past in
his typical gonzo style Thompson got
high and swam in the hotel pool hunter
missed Muhammad Ali's fight completely
when asked what he thought of the match
Thompson replied what fight oh I didn't
go to the fight I stayed in the hotel
swimming pool I lay on my back looking
at the moon coming up and the only
person in the hotel came and stared at
me a long time before he went away
maybe he thought I was a corpse I
floated there naked I'd thrown a pound
and a half of marijuana into the pool it
was what I had left and I'm not trying
to smuggle it out of this country and it
stuck together there and a sort of plot
and then it began to spread out in a
green slick it was very luxurious
floating naked in that stuff though it's
not the best way to obtain a high
needless to say paying him to get high
and not write a story isn't exactly good
for business
stunts like this proved that he was no
longer as prolific as he once was he was
forced to take a break from writing
[Music]
Thomson had earned a significant amount
of money from his book sales and selling
movie rights so he was able to
essentially retire from his journalism
career when they began filming Fear and
Loathing in Las Vegas in 1997 Johnny
Depp wanted to get to know him so that
he could portray the character more
accurately on the day they met Depp said
that he was asked to meet Hunter s
Thompson at the Woody Creek tavern
Hunter made a grand entrance by holding
a cattle prod that was lighting up the
room with sparks people weren't jumping
out of the way as Thompson shouted out
of my way you bastards obviously this
made quite the impression of Johnny Depp
and he started living with Hunter s
Thompson in order to understand him
better they spent many long nights
shooting guns blowing things up and
reading books to one another during this
time hunter would ask Johnny Depp to
read out his own work to him Thompson
explains him the exact cadence of how he
wanted his work to be read Depp stumbled
upon the unpublished manuscripts of a
book called The Rum Diary which told the
story of one of his adventures in Puerto
Rico and he was in his early 20s he read
it since encouraged Thompson to publish
it so he finally did Johnny Depp would
also go on to star in a movie version of
the run diary in 2011 four years
Thompson had told his friends and family
that he planned to kill himself one day
when he met his second wife Anita when
she began working as his personal
assistant in 1999 they fell in love and
got married that happened in 2003 On
February the 20th 2005 Anita had just
made him breakfast and she noticed that
Hunter was acting strange he told her to
get out of the room this shocked her
because he had never before been so
cruel to her she left the house and he
called her to apologize and say that she
should come back if she wanted to
however she began to hear creaking
noises on the other ends and eater
assumed he was about to use the
typewriter but when she arrived home she
realized that he had committed suicide
and those clicking noises were the
sounds of him preparing a gun
his son Juan was the one to find the
body because he'd been at home at the
time even long before his suicide he was
already made
plans for a monument to be built for his
funeral and even had a film crew
document him preparing his last will and
testament he asked to have his ashes
shot out of a fist shaped cannon loads
of his celebrity friends showed up to
his funeral and it looks more like an
extravagant party there was a stage full
of Japanese drummers and colorful
fireworks went off before the ashes were
scattered over the mountains of Colorado
after his death his wife Anita didn't
want to touch anything in his office
which he called the war room years later
after she'd had time to grieve it became
clear that hunter s Thompson had become
a legendary writer she decided to turn
it into a museum and allow his fans to
see it she also runs an organization
called the gonzo foundation where she
plans to open up our farm for writing
retreats even though there are plenty of
his friends and family who still miss
him dearly Thompson wouldn't have wanted
anyone to feel sad about his death he
once said life should not be a journey
to the grave with the intention of
arriving safely in a pretty and
well-preserved body but rather to skid
in broadside in a cloud of smoke
thoroughly used up totally worn out and
loudly proclaiming wow what a ride so I
really hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do give us
a thumbs up below we've got brand new
videos several times a week so be sure
to subscribe to this channel also if you
think about something else for me why
not check out my other channel called
today I found out you'll find that
linked to below and as always thank you
for watching
[Music]